[Music]
all right so the the previous
presentations have all looks really
slick and really nice and I thought I'd
I thought I'd mix it up with something
that you didn't even know someone could
do as a presentation which is you
guessed it a series of screenshots but
but I have a moderate reason for this
it's I want to show some student
generated content but I wanted to make
it anonymous so I really tastefully
blurred some things that you will notice
when it happens let's see this is gonna
get bigger yeah yes it did okay great so
so I taught a math 230 and 231 those are
a first-year sequence of courses
it's very intense course for people who
are usually first years and they are
rather sure they want to do math and
they're definitely right about to do a
lot of it and success in this course and
in the major more generally is usually
highly correlated with if you're able to
form study groups in the first year if
you're able to find people you like to
work with sort of at university the
students are the most important part of
the whole thing and students working
with students is one of the most
important things the students can be
doing here so one of my main goals was
to try to figure out how to how to get
students working together how to get
students kind of all buying into this
idea of a community and well yeah so
what I did is I had a canvas page and
let's see what we got so it's got you
know a syllabus boring things um this is
gonna be the page for both 2:30 which I
did in the fall and also 231 just
finishing up now
I like kind of mix and match those two
pages so one thing that I got is some
assignments which are assignments and
the first thing I thought the canvas
page should be is useful to the students
before I can get them to use some some
of that content that'll presumably help
them form connections or help them get
more out of the course I thought I'd
meet them where they're at and make it
and something that they actually want to
do so assignments is something they have
to do and in a usual assignments they
can click on things see what the
assignments are usual stuff they also
have files which I
got oodles of stuff in here we've got
assignments also uh tech files for the
assignments which just helps them type
up their their stuff its content what
else do we got in here though we got
course notes which is not something that
they like students like course notes as
it turns out and it's something that at
least gets him here and I have got a
couple flavours so course notes are sort
of a bridge between students being there
and then something that they can see on
canvas where they say oh yeah that's
something that I kind of interacted with
at least that was present during the
creation of those course notes it's a
it's a step it's a step like here's
whatever the heck this day is and yep
that those were the course notes so I
was in the teal room which I do
recommend it's a good room of course
notes they flip through and they see
whatever it is
some days I did whatever these are these
presentations would look nicer nicer
than this one but oh yeah Katz's that's
if you have if you have a prime number
of cats you should you should do have
psychology but with your cats it's
highly recommended anyway so so so
gimmicks it kind of get the students in
but when it starts getting sort of more
personal more things that they care
about more communal ziz may be
announcements and then I'm going to hit
up my favorite which was the Piazza
feature announcements the thing you can
do routine stuff like hey here's study
materials or hey here are office hours
or here's reading more if you were
curious about that thing you can jump
real in-depth and hear stuff if you're
curious about it or for me that the
always thing that I need is here's the
things I lied about today sorry about
that and here's how to correct those
course notes
ah but but then you can get some some
other interesting sort of announcements
like hey everybody there are free
t-shirts that you can get here's and
here's one of these and math t-shirts
and then that's that's suddenly
something that I'm using the course not
to not to necessarily just to be course
content but instead to sort of a sell
the package of the social community and
you have a guy here got shirts here's me
advertising an event that was happening
I was a cool event a one-woman play
about being a woman in math because
would
so so next I want to talk about as
Piazza so Piazza is yeah if you don't
know it's a feature which is an external
tool that can plug into canvas and the
the idea is students can post things
it's a forum students post they can post
things anonymously so they can say hey
everybody I'm really confused about what
happened today but I don't want to you
know slap my name on there and maybe I
don't want to go to office hours because
I don't know it's whatever - in the
clock in the morning and they just want
to know the answer without leaving the
butteri or whatever so they can post
stuff and you can get students posting
questions hey what the heck's going on
here and then another student could
answer oh I think this is what's going
on here the instructor can say yep
that's what's going on here or the
instructor can you know make it more
nuanced well actually maybe you want to
consider this or you can edit everything
students can go back and forth you can
also generate so I use this to generate
not just questions that the students ask
but also here's me I started doing a
thing where students will post their
solutions to homeworks because it was
partly borne out of laziness I didn't
want to write up homework solutions and
partly it doesn't sound like a bad idea
so students post their own solutions
here's the solution I did for problem
four well here's my solution to problem
six and they can do this anonymously and
then they can read off each other they
can learn they can see other ways to
approach the same thing more ways to
sort of build this community and this
was a this was motivated by I gave them
I gave him too much homework and then I
said and if you want you can not do one
of those homework assignments or
homework problems if you do one of these
so it's a little carrot similarly they
can post their course notes here's my
notes for the day well here's my notes
and well here's my notes and it's the
same sort of thing and they can be all
anonymous you can collaborate you can
make shared files it's brought to the
tool for this I don't know that's that's
what we did though
what else do I got here study materials
for the exams here are study materials
and know here's my study materials
here's my detailed study guide oh great
cool and students are doing a lot of
stuff but then they also started using
it for like I don't know fun course
stuff like one group me to rule them all
so that way they can all collaborate and
and get all on the same page or whatever
if
they want so so it started out with say
more Piazza as routine questions and
answers but you can use it to generate
more I don't know what more more nuanced
interactions you can use it to then
ultimately have students as like a
communal message board or something
which I think really helps with the the
buy-in which is key so that's that's all
I got but I forgot any questions I'm
happy to answer any the question is how
often I get notified about Theotis so
that's in a setting I can get daily
notifications if I want I can get
notifications every time something's
posted I can probably turn off
notifications altogether me I have them
I have them about I think I have them
set to whenever they get posted so like
the day before an exam everyone's
posting their study materials and their
study guides and whatever it is so I get
a lot of notifications then and I just
ignore them but usually a it's a
question like hey Pat I'm pretty sure
there's an egregious error in your
homework and the problem for should be
something drastically different and I
read it and I say well that's correct
yeah I've got to change that so those I
can kind of respond to immediately if I
feel like it basically look at that
every day you personally I got nothing
else today the question in the back hi
Pat thank you that was a great
presentation I have a question about the
extent to which your efforts to build
community drew in the students who
aren't traditionally represented in math
did that did you see that happening that
is something that I very much care about
it's hard for me to compare I don't know
what a student how would engage a
student would be otherwise but for
instances so it's a - it's a two
semester sequence and there's usually a
big drop-off between the first semester
in the second semester because students
decide well this isn't for me or well I
didn't make any friends in the first
semester so I'm just gonna leave and
disproportionately that's females
non-binary students people of color it's
really districts them historically and
that's not a Yale thing that's just a
them thing maybe just an academics thing
I don't know but and this year there
wasn't so much of a drop-off the the
percent of the demographic
representation at the beginning of the
first semester is very close to what is
at the end so that's a plus there are a
couple things that might be contributing
to that that's something I'm keeping in
mind yes yeah just a little bit of the
philosophy behind posting their
solutions for the homework which sounds
amazing to me and I would definitely
adopt that how do you go about it is it
right after they submit their own
problem sets or how do you make sure to
maintain the integrity okay yeah so uh
the the integrity of it all is a big
level is trust I I post things about the
homework problem itself is something
that they could look up without trying
too hard some of it they can just Google
letter for letter and something close
enough will pop up that they can solve
and they can just copy if they wanted to
so having students post homework
solutions isn't so much of a oh now they
can suddenly cheat the in my class they
could do that if they wanted to anyway
plus I strongly encourage collaboration
anyway so students who want to work
together already do and they just at the
top of their homeworks they say well
yeah I collaborated with so-and-so we
the other person and but yeah ultimately
I just kind of trust them and I think I
think that's working out for me the the
exams and such are on par with the with
the homework grid so that's an indicator
that something's happening yeah so we've
seen that canvas supports Cyrillic and
Arabic does it support math it does it
does to various degrees of success let's
see if I can magically find one that had
there we go beautiful so this one
actually well it is what it is I'm
pretty sure that's that's the the that
feature that they have yeah so that it
supports late equi chip you've ever
tried to type math in a computer before
that would be the thing if anything you
would might try to use and yes it does
support that you have to just like type
double dollar signs or something
and it just kind of automatically works
that's convenient you could also copy
and paste if you're so inclined
[Applause]
[Music]